[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale et
régionale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition
tout de suite les titres de ce lundi 16
avril l'appel d'urgence a été lancé
début avril les réserves de produits
sanguins sont en baisse à quelques
semaines des ponts du mois de mai une
situation difficile dans la région qui a
enregistré 15 % de donneurs en moins
pour en parler stéphane noël directeur
de l'établissement français du sang ile
de france
c'est une initiative de quelques
enseignants de maurepas la deuxième
journée de la citoyenneté et du civisme
se tenait vendredi dernier élève de cm1
cm2 et 6e ont participé à un parcours à
travers des stands thématiques sécurité
routière dangers d'internet ou encore
initiation aux premiers secours
et puis une première attrape la ville
organisait hier son semi-marathon un
parcours à la fois urbain et nature et
les coureurs ont arpenté les rues
trappistes et les sentiers de l'île de
loisirs retour à la fin de ce journal et
200 motos et 40 voitures au départ des
yvelines direction paris elles ont
rejoint hier dimanche la mobilisation
des motards en colère
plusieurs centaines de manifestants ont
bloqué le boulevard périphérique pour
contester la limitation de vitesse à 80
km/heure cette mesure voulue par le
gouvernement entrera en vigueur le 1er
juillet et sur les routes secondaires
sans séparateur central ça ne marchera
pas selon les représentants des motards
en colère pour eux la priorité c'est
l'état des routes les territoires
franciliens sont différents les
problèmes restent néanmoins les mêmes
face à la baisse des dotations de l'état
les collectivités sont contraintes de
trouver des solutions et des livres
comme maurepas et coignières par exemple
ont fait le choix de se réunir en
communes nouvelles et les départements
d'ile-de-france eux se rapprochent ils
ont lancé un pacte de solidarité inter
départementale concrètement un fonds
d'investissement commun va être créé
reportage d'olivier zanetta cyril
chauvin pour vyas grand paris
les sept présidents de départements
d'ile-de-france toutes couleurs
politiques confondues main dans la main
pour une annonce inédite face à la
baisse des financements de l'état qui
empêche les départements les plus
pauvres de réaliser leur projet ils vont
créer un fonds d'investissement nous
considérons qu'il ya des territoires qui
sont plus en difficulté que d'autres qui
méritent donc des investissements
supplémentaires et on dit à l'état
donnez-nous l'autorisation d'aller
utiliser de l'argent du département des
yvelines du département des
hauts-de-seine ou du département de
l'essonne pour aller en seine saint
denis pour aller dans le val d'oise pour
aller dans le val de marne pour aller en
seine-et-marne pourquoi pas parce que
nous considérons de ses investissement
participe à l'intérêt général
ce fonds de solidarité sera alimenté par
une partie des dépenses
d'investissements des sept départements
des investissements qui s'élèvent
aujourd'hui à 2 milliards d'euros par an
les départements franciliens les moins
riches pourraient ainsi voir leur projet
se concrétiser nous apportons de l'aide
à nos communes en investissement nous
avions 50 millions d'euros il y a quinze
ou vingt ans aujourd'hui nous avons mis
au budget augmenter cette année de 2
millions nous sommes à 27 millions
d'euros
donc voyez que le fond s'amenuisent et
si on n'a pas effectivement ce concours
de nos collègues des autres départements
qui eux ont un investissement beaucoup
plus important que le nôtre
à ce moment là il ya un moment où on
aura beaucoup de difficultés pour aider
nos communes les élus attendent
maintenant le feu vert du gouvernement
pour se lancer
les expérimentations étant prévue par
l'état dans la constitution
on peut démarrer dès demain assure les
départements franciliens
c'est une période régulièrement sous
tension pendant les vacances de pâques
et le mois de mai la collecte de sang
est fortement ralentie pourtant les
besoins restent les mêmes et les stocks
doivent être réapprovisionnées bonsoir
ses fans aux ailes ou soit vous êtes le
directeur de l'établissement français
d'île de france merci d'avoir accepté
cette invitation
alors au début du mois d'avril le ffs a
lancé un appel d'urgence aux dons pour
faire face justement cette période
difficile
trois semaines plus tard au début de ses
vacances de printemps quel est l'état
des réserves des produits sanguins est
ce que la situation est encore préoccupe
la situation reste tendue l'appel aux
dons que nous avons lancée en début de
mois a apporté quelques effets et
heureusement
néanmoins la situation reste tendue pour
deux raisons la première il faut être
conscient que les besoins en produits
sanguins sont des besoins qui sont
permanents d'accord les malades ne
prennent pas de vacances et tous les
jours nous avons besoin en france de
produits sanguins nous ont besoin de
produits sanguins parce que ce sont des
produits qui ne se stocke pas les
plaquettes par exemple aux cinq jours de
durée de vie de fait tous les jours tous
les jours tous les jours nous devons
impérativement collecter des produits
soient des plaquettes dans nos centres
fixes soit ce que l'on appelle du sang
total qui est collecté feu nos collectes
mobiles pas en permanence produire les
plaquettes dont ont besoin des patients
et c'est un challenge quotidien que de
produire ces plaques disque est
important de savoir c'est qu'en ile de
france nous consommer nous nous
consommons pardon 25% des plaques est
délivré une accord au niveau national
c'est à dire qu'une plaquette sur quatre
délivrés en france et en ile de france
et donc il est absolument impératif tous
les jours que de pouvoir prélever du
sang cinq jours pour laquelle je crois
que ces 90 jours pour les globules moto2
ou 42 jours voilà 42 jours pour les
globules rouges effectivement et de fait
nous sommes en permanence sous tension
nous vivons généralement avec 12 jours
de stocks actuellement nous sommes en
dessous de ça nous avons dix jours de
stock voit un petit peu moins sur
certains groupes
de fait nous sommes sous tension
d'autant que les vacances ont commencé
il y à des pans qui sont extrêmement
importants vous pouvez semaine blanche
la semelle de la semaine - et surtout la
semaine du 8 mai sont des semaines
qu'ils sont extrêmement difficiles
et comme vous l'avez compris nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre d'avoir des
interruptions de collègues pendant ces
périodes là de fait nous devons
absolument connectés en permanence nous
appelons vraiment les donneurs à se
mobiliser
d'autant que nous avons d'autres
conséquences qui aujourd'hui nous
impacte et en particulier les mouvements
sociaux les mouvements sociaux par
exemple ça aldrin à devoir annuler des
collectes en raison de lieu de
manifestation dans paris qui empêchent
certaines de nos collègues de se tenir
donc nous appelons vraiment tous les
donneurs aujourd'hui assurent leur
maximum pour venir nous voir et donner
maintenant et en plus c'est à prendre en
compte il ya eu
en ce début d'année une baisse des dons
de 15% on peut l'expliquer par une
mauvaise météo de la neige des
températures glaciales qui on peut le
dire ont refroidi les donneurs cette
année les conditions météorologiques je
ne sais pas s'ils ont refroidi les
donneurs en tout cas ils ont empêché un
certain nombre d'entre eux de venir au
moment où les toute la banlieue
parisienne et paris était très impacté
par ces chutes de neige qui nous ont
empêchés de collecter correctement
pendant pas mal de jours
effectivement et nous avons ce retard
que nous devons absolument rattraper
mais surtout aujourd'hui la mobilisation
est importante pour faire face à ces
semaines qui arrivent nous restait un
peu moins de trois minutes rappelons le
à quoi sert-il ses produits sanguins ça
sert concrètement à sauver des vies leur
206 s'est produite sanguin servent
concrètement à sauver des vies
au delà des images que nous avons vues à
la suite des événements de novembre 2015
dont tout le monde se souvient et s'il
est vraiment la partie visible de
l'iceberg il faut savoir que ces
produits sanguins nous permettent de
nous permettent de garder de participer
au traitement de leucémie ou ethernet de
faire face à des gens qui ont des
maladies génétiques la drépanocytose par
exemple et les gens qui sont atteints de
cette maladie vivent et survivent grâce
aux dons du sang et grâce aux
transfusions qu'ils ont de manière
périodique mais c'est aussi les
accidentés de la route etc etc donc se
donne sans permis en france de soigner à
peu près un million de personnes par an
avec un don de sang vous participez vous
contribuez à soigner trois patients
votre don de sang permet de faire un
plasma permet de faire un concentré de
globules rouges et avec 5,25
nous fabriquons une plaquette si
indispensable pour nos patients et qui
peut donner dans quelles conditions on
peut donner
alors qui peut donner dans quelles
conditions alors vous pouvez donner soit
sur des sites fixes et dans les yvelines
nous avons un site approché ni le
versailles nous avons un autre site fixe
qui se trouve à poissy à grandpuits
nous organisons en ile-de-france à peu
près 3000 collectes mobiles cette année
à peu près 500 sur le département des
yvelines et vous pouvez trouver le lieu
de collecte le plus proche de chez vous
sur notre site internet dont 200 points
est fait ce point ci accueille fr merci
beaucoup
vous pouvez trouver la collecte la plus
proche de chez vous
ensuite il ya des conditions
d'éligibilité elles sont très simples
avoir plus de 18 ans avoir moins de 70
ans
si vous n'allez jamais donner votre sang
à 65 ans 65 ans et l'âge limite pour
pouvoir donner son sang si on n'a jamais
donné avant ensuite peser plus de 50 kg
est en bonne santé et ça prend pas
beaucoup de temps
ça prend acte de données par lui-même le
don par l'e-mail dure 10 à 15 minutes
entre le moment où vous arrivez sur
notre site et le moment où vous quittez
sachant qu'il y a un accueil un
entretien pré don le don et après il ya
un moment très important de collations
et de réhydratation il faut compter à
peu près 45 minutes il nous reste 30
secondes un petit message à nos
téléspectateurs peut être adressée pour
véhiculer un message important
aujourd'hui il faut donner son sang ne
pas procrastiner ne pas attendre demain
le don c'est maintenant merci à stéphane
noël d'avoir été avec nous directeur de
l'établissement
on sait d'île de france et vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
don du sang aux sites internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
la citoyenneté une notion importante en
république mais qui peut être floue pour
les plus jeunes c'est pour mieux
comprendre cette thématique est
organisée depuis l'an passé à maurepas
une journée et citoyenneté et civisme la
deuxième édition se tenait vendredi
dernier à la halle du marché des élèves
de l'école mal me donne des baissière
défricher du collège louis pergaud ont
participé à un parcours imaginés par
leurs enseignants montage signé jules
grevy j'ouvre la bouche
j'ouvre la bouche de mes victimes je
regarde ok je vais coller mon oreille
collée majou rapprochés et je vais
regarder son ventre pour voir s'il
respire gestes qui sauvent
sensibilisation avec les forces de
l'ordre quiz sur les institutions ou
encore circuit sécurité routière autant
d'ateliers auxquels ont participé près
de 180 élèves de maurepas vendredi 13
avril des classes de cm1 cm2 et 6e
toutes venues à cette journée préparée
par leurs enseignants afin de mieux
appréhender un thème cher qui figurent
au programme scolaire la citoyenneté
les élèves sont capables de comprendre
très jeune les notions de citoyenneté
ils peuvent les transmettre dans leur
famille les retransmettre à l'école et
ils sont tout à fait capables de
de comprendre ces notions là des plus
jeune âge au cours de la journée les
enfants réunis en petits groupes ont pu
suivre un parcours à travers une dizaine
de stands
rencontre avec des pompiers policiers et
bénévoles j'utilise un côté genou pour
tirer ma victime et regardez c'est
magique c'est un levier ça bascule la
victime faire le plein de connaissances
civiques y adopter certains bons
réflexes notamment pour les premiers
secours
tu mets ton bras comme ça et ensuite on
devra durer comme ça il ya suite et si
tu écoutes qui s'il respecte on a appris
à savoir comment utiliser internet
comment
sauver des vies avec les pompiers moi je
peux supporter quelqu'un si je retrouve
quelqu'un par terre et aussi j'apprends
comment ne pas être renversé par une
voiture par exemple quand il traverse
une journée qui a séduit la municipalité
et l'inspection académique le rendez
vous devrait être élargie dans les
prochaines années aux autres écoles de
maurepas quand la technologie se met au
service de la santé le comité des
yvelines de l'association valentin hauy
organisait à samedi une après-midi
thématiques elle servait informer sur
les avancées en faveur des déficients
visuels
vous découvrirez notamment dans ce
reportage une canne connectés marylène
iapichino et patrick jacques de dixmude
objectif autonomie le comité des
yvelines de l'association valentin haüy
a convié différents acteurs pour par les
technologies et évolution de la médecine
autour de la déficience visuelle
c'est très important pour nos amis
déficients visuels de voir les pros les
projets parce qu'il ya un certain nombre
de produits qu'on leur a présenté
aujourd'hui qui sont au stade de projet
ou de prototypes et les développements
de la médecine qui sont pour eux des
facteurs d'espoir extraordinaire quand
le professeur loger leur explique qu'on
va pouvoir greffer des cornées donc on
va pouvoir arriver à l'oeil artificiel
pour des gens qui voit plus du tout
c'est un espoir colossal donc cédé
journée très importante pour eux parmi
les objets présentés le panda guide un
casque de réalité augmentée qui filme
l'environnement et décrit les objets
autour de la personne et une canne
connectés nous mais cher par qu'est ce
que c'est cher pas finalement bas c'est
ce qu'on appelle un assistant
intelligent
pourquoi pas ce qu'il va apporter des
informations lors des déplacements que
les personnes déficientes visuelles ne
pourrait pas avoir tout seul ou
difficilement à l'aide d'une oreillette
sans fil et d'un système gps l'appareil
guide l'utilisateur de la direction à
prendre autant d'attentes pour son
prochain bus via vous dire arrêtez de
dire et son temps et vous allez entendre
habib sy volet pasta rêve fait rien il
va dire automatiquement le deuxième
arrêt tout seul un dispositif déjà
utilisé par plusieurs dizaines de
personnes en france et qui a un coût 700
euros sont à débourser pour une canne
connecter pour les mal et non voyants la
technologie n'est pas la seule réponse à
avoir à leur demande d'autonomie
mais côté accessibilité dans les gars
dans
j'ai dans la rue dans tout ce que vous
voulez l'activité en france et on est en
retard beaucoup de choses un nouvel
invité avec moi sur ce plateau priscilla
lopes bonsoir vous êtes à la tête d'une
jeune start up en incubation en ce
moment même au ski cuba
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son nom c'est
au d'avis alors d'avis et une plateforme
de services à la personne elle a pour
but de faciliter le maintien à domicile
des personnes âgées handicapées ou
dépendantes première question pourquoi
lancer cette plateforme finalement
pourquoi cette thématique que de l'aide
à la personne vous vous tient à coeur
alors moi j'ai près de 10 ans
d'expérience dans ce secteur de l'aide
au maintien à domicile donc en faveur
des personnes âgées personnes
handicapées qui souhaitent rester à
domicile et je pars d'un constat qui est
que c'est très compliqué pour les dents
familiaux donc le parent l'enfant le
frère la voisine deux de ces personnes
de trouver le prestataire qui correspond
au mieux aux besoins de la personne à
aider et pourquoi à votre avis il ya
cette complication est ce qu'il ya un
manque de visibilité peut-être sur les
solutions disponibles pour pour la
personne qui souhaite être accompagné
tout à fait vous avez complètement
raison en fait moi tous les jours je
rencontre donc d'aider des personnes
aidants familiaux qui me disent c'est
très compliqué on n'a pas confiance on
sait pas vers qui se tourner déjà si je
vous dis siad achat d appât qu'on ait un
conseil départemental
vous ne savez pas qui fait quoi c'est un
tissu qui est très complexe
donc dans un premier temps déjà en
accompagne ces personnes pour comprendre
qui fait quoi et ensuite on va
diagnostiquer de besoins et trouver les
prestataires qui ont les prestataires
qui sont qualifiés par aude avions fait
un audit pour véritablement comprendre
ce qu'ils sont en mesure d'apporter par
rapport à leurs concurrents et du coup
on fait match et l'offre et la demande
donc l'eau et une mise en relation
directe de la personne qui demande le
service et du prestataire tout à fait
qu'ils aient facilité du coup du coup ça
fonctionne comment concrètement on prend
contact avec vous donc vous avez soit
www.ovi.com 18 point fr donc là le site
internet sur lequel vous pouvez nous
envoyer votre besoin ensuite nous on
vous on vous rappelle où vous nous
appelez directement au 01 34 94 09 69 ça
s'affiche actuellement on voit de
l'écran super et du coup on vous
accompagne pour trouver le bon
prestataire déjà pour vous aiguiller
pour répondre à vos questions et ensuite
à vous donner une liste de prestataires
qualifiés spécifiquement pour votre
besoin donc par exemple si vous avez un
besoin sur une personne qui a la maladie
d'alzheimer certains prestataires forme
leur personnel à la maladie d'alzheimer
plutôt que autres maladies telles que
parkinson
certains proposent une badgeuse à
domicile ce qui peut être intéressant
pour ces personnes qui sont pas
forcément qu'ils n'ont pas forcément
toutes leurs têtes pour d'autres il
n'est pas forcément utile
donc voilà en fait on fait vraiment le
tri pour que vous puissiez trouver le
bon prestataire qualifié et de l'autre
côté on accompagne aussi les
prestataires pour qu'il puisse répondre
au mieux aux besoins du territoire et on
démarre actuellement donc sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et le ski cube m'a très très bien aidé à
ce sujet puisqu'on a pu du coup établir
un partenariat
vous êtes un cube et au stick usa vous
amène quoi concrètement ça vous apporte
quoi concrètement eh ben c'est les
bonnes portes d'entrée puisque en fait
on démarre avec le service solidarité de
de la communauté d'agglomération une
expérimentation ce qui nous permet
d'avoir de nous lancer simplement avec
les partenaires du territoire
voilà c'est ce qui nous permet de
démarrer sur cette attente c'est à dire
qu'en amont vous avez déjà une série de
prestataires avec lesquels vous
travaillez qui sont déjà identifiés
exactement on a une vingtaine de
prestataires avec qui avec qui on
travaille on a déjà diagnostiqué des
besoins on envoie à ses besoins aux
prestataires et les prestataires nous
font un retour sur ce qu'ils apportent
en plus
sur sur le besoin exprimé est ce qu'il y
aussi une sorte de service après vente
pour savoir auprès du client si ça s'est
bien déroulé peut-être mettre en place
un indice de satisfaction tout à fait en
fait on va chercher la satisfaction des
bénéficiaires et c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de vérifier la qualité de
service de chacun des prestataires et du
coup de faire une mise en relation en
toute confiance
on va vérifier à j + 15 puis à j + 30 et
ensuite trimestriellement la
satisfaction du bénéficiaire sur les
points qui au départ était
identifiés lors du diagnostic et sur
lesquels le prestataire s'est engagé
notamment sur la formation du personnel
du personnel vous en parlais juste avant
la plateforme est aujourd'hui
opérationnel là c'est en phase
d'expérimentation sur le territoire de
50 ans tout est fait en fait on démarre
sur le territoire de saint quentin avec
les collectivités locales et du coup on
peut démarrer en identifiant les besoins
d'aidé des familles qui habitent le
territoire
dernière question à laquelle sont les
objectifs pour vous dans les prochains
mois alors ben on a déjà sept des
expérimentations qui démarre ensuite on
va développer puisque c'est une
plateforme collaboratif les espaces des
prestataires d'accord pour qu'ils
puissent plus facilement encore obtenir
les besoins et développer aussi l'espace
donc des collectivités pour qu'il puisse
avoir une visibilité sur les besoins de
ce secteur et ça n'existe pas sur le sur
le territoire français aujourd'hui et
pour plus d'informations et prendre
contact avec un opérateur les
coordonnées de davie s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci priscilla lopes merci avec
nous je m'appelle vous êtes là la
fondatrice de cette plateforme de
services à la personne aux d'avis on
reste à saint quentin en yvelines pour
tout autre chose le top départ de du
deuxième à cyclo défi ce lundi matin une
vingtaine de jeunes de quartiers
prioritaires du département mais aussi
du canada de la suisse et de la belgique
se sont retrouvés au vélodrome nationale
après une visite des lieux ils sont
partis pour cinq jours de vélo dans les
yvelines et à paris parmi les étapes les
berges de seine à maisons-laffitte la
visite du louvre et de l'assemblée
nationale et les jeunes yvelinois iront
à leur tour au canada cet été pour
réaliser le cyclo-défi québécois qui
existe depuis 2012 un moment de partage
et de découverte écouter à ses propos
recueillis par un camille lambert
il ya de très très belles choses dans
les yvelines sont ces échanges la qui
m'intéresse parce qu'on parle de tous
les thèmes on parle de l'environnement
de la citoyenneté de la culture de la
solidarité du sport et du handicap ce
sont les différents thèmes sur lesquels
on débat pendant les cinq jours de cyclo
défi
nous on a même des jeunes et ces gens là
à la rencontre d'autres jeunes à
découvrir la réalité partage et
hinges donc c'est l'fun ça permet aux
jeunes aussi de grandir parce que les
voyages ça fait grandir donc et même les
jeunes des yvelines le fait qu'ils
rencontrent d'autres jeunes qui viennent
d'ailleurs le partage d'expérience et
c'est vraiment essentiel pour les jeunes
c'est une tradition à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse pour la 26e
année consécutive la jean racine était
organisée samedi et dimanche
au programme 9 randonnée en vtt dont une
en nocturne et trois parcours sur route
de 10 à 110 kilomètres dans le
magnifique cadre de la vallée de
chevreuse un concept populaire qui a
attiré plus de quatre mille cyclistes
débutants et confirmés ont on écoute
l'un des organisateurs au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude sur cet
événement il n'y a pas de chrono il n'y
a pas de pression on peut le voir là
autour de moi c'est des gens qui
discutent autour de tables c'est pas un
événement professionnel on va être dans
un lieu associatif on reste dans un
événement qui est amateur mais pour
autant d'ailleurs proposer quelque chose
de qualité et qui est très intéressant
pour tout le monde
allez encore un mot de ce sport je vous
en parlais dans les titres le premier
semi-marathon de trappes se déroulait ce
dimanche un parcours inédit 80% en
pleine nature 20% en urbain un parcours
qui a attiré 168 à courageux reportage
de nicolas quere levitt et michael et
demi d'euros une grande première à
trappes la ville a organisé ce dimanche
15 avril son tout premier semi marathon
a rendez-vous dans les cartons depuis de
nombreux mois
on a
on avait un besoin amant qui existait
sur cette ville c'est que les trappistes
couraient tous individuellement mais ne
se retrouver jamais ensemble pour une
course unique
donc on a choisi de l'organiser cette
année elle répond à un vrai besoin
ce dimanche ils étaient 168 inscrits au
départ les coureurs en débuté par deux
kilomètres en zone urbaine avant de
s'engouffrer dans l'île de loisirs un
secteur qui représentait 80% du parcours
on profite vraiment un cadre
exceptionnel avec lille de loisirs
beaucoup de coureurs spontanément
attrapé dans les environs viennent
courir sur l'île de loisirs donc ils
connaissent le cadre est franchement
profiter du bruit des oiseaux de la
musique de l'île de loisirs qui est si
singulière de l'aspect nature de cette
course c'est un bénéfice dont on va
profiter à fond sur la ligne d'arrivée
younès il del moudden du club d'evreux a
emporté cette première épreuve le
coureur a dompté les 21 km du parcours
en 1h 10 minutes et 27 secondes
[Musique]
en plus beaucoup de
la forêt a pas de coups de la russe ils
devront aussi mais j'étais réalise le
premier 10 km mais après un très long
métrage et icare mais j'ai fait une
tranquille et j'ai gagné vu le succès
rencontré cette année une nouvelle
édition devrait être à nouveau organisé
sur trappe en 2019 de la performance des
victoires et à d'autres compétitions à
suivre après ce journal dans le 7-8
sport présentée par michael et demi
d'euros mais avant ça pour refermer à
cette édition les pompiers au secours de
l'environnement des personnages de
bandes dessinées sont les héros du
prochain agenda scolaire de versailles
grand parc
quatre classes ont planché sur les
illustrations de cette nouvelle édition
le thème cette année les déchets nickel
et demi d'euros et mélanie poker se sont
glissés dans une classe j'ai travaillé
sur les bulles et l'écriture est alors
au passage aux autres est un personnage
dans la maison en flammes et des nuages
j'ai dessiné des débuts naître des
tableaux et personnages leurs pompiers
prennent vie pour porter secours à
l'environnement cette classe de cm2 de
versailles participe à la sixième
édition de l'agenda scolaire un projet
pluridisciplinaire autour des déchets on
a travaillé en sciences on a travaillé
en production d'écrits on a travaillé en
recherche
mais la finalité c'est d'arriver à ses
planchers au travail voilà ça c'est la
finalité du projet pour aller aux jeux
aux éco-gestes faut d'abord connaître et
comprendre les enjeux qu'il ya derrière
pour vous prenez un bouteille de jus
d'orange le matin
il faut réfléchir de façon systémique
d'où il vient comme on les crée comment
elle a été produit et qu'elle comptait
de ces déchets près 220 enfants quatre
classes de l'agglomération de versailles
grand parc ont travaillé deux jours avec
un bédéiste cette année c sté de
dessinateur belge
ils ont plein d'idées plus que moi du
coup c'est un peu frustrant mais non
mais je suis assez surpris parce que
c'est quand même un projet concerne
conséquent au niveau du du boulot à
investir et je trouve qu'ils ont plein
d'idées ils sont très réactifs
il dessine vachement bien en fait donc
voilà je pense que je vais les engager
les élèves ont donné avant les vacances
leur dernier coup de crayon plus de dix
mille exemplaires de cet agenda seront
distribués dès le mois de juin
mélanie poker sur des images de michael
et demi d'euros c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal merci de l'avoir suivi ripley et
reportages a consultés sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 très bonne soirée et excellent de
semaine à tous
[Musique]